hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video sieht man mal wieder zurück
nachdem ich gestern geburtstag hatte und
die tage davor in wien waren könnt ihr
übrigens auch alles mehr oder weniger in
lukas blogs nachvollziehen
ich mache heute mal wieder ein video und
zwar gucke ich mir heute meinen
doppelgänger an ich hab euch auf
instagram mit aufs web chat darum
gebeten dafür mehr bilder von leuten die
so aussehen wie ich zu schicken und klar
auch zwischen sind echten paar dabei
rumgekommen das video macht einen ganz
einfachen grund und vererbten irgendwie
seitdem ich youtube mache habe ich voll
oft dass leute mit seinen helfern in
bocklemünd gesehen oder ich hab dich
gestern in wolfsburg gesehen ort wo ich
selbst überhaupt nicht verändern wo
einfach leute leute gesehen haben die
anscheinend so aufwendig beteiligten
faires passiert was ich fordere
zugesteckt bekommen habe von einer
person die so aussieht wie ich und die
leute die nicht das bild gezeigt habe
meinte alonso
das verfahren ist voll greifen zeigt
euch heute einfach mal ein paar leute
die wir aus dem winkel los mit dem
allerersten foto ich glaube dieses foto
dürften insbesondere die maut fans unter
euch schon kennen
foto handelt sich um ein foto wo
angeblich luca und ich drauf bin
das system schule des partners auf den
fans die sich küssen und irgendwie hat
das mal angefangen
foto für maus fan factions oder sowas
genommen wurde
also singt nicht luca und sich auf
diesem bild vereinigung sieht ein
bisschen aus wie der andere passt und
seitdem wenn es auf diesem foto verlinkt
und wurde auch tatsächlich stand von
echten bekanntschaft aus meinem echten
privaten leben gefragt
stimmt das eigentlich eigentlich schwul
welches foto gewinnt darauf verlegt
wurde
er danke student community
das sind weder luca noch ist aber zum
festival ist dann kennt ihr vielleicht
aus einem von lukas videos diesen typen
wir dass viele schon auf di luca
reagiert und jahre typ sieht mir ein
bisschen ähnlich es gibt andere leute
die mir ähnlich versehen aber der fang
hat extrem viele fragen zugeschickt als
ich gemerkt habe mir meinen blog
verlängern stecken welt und ich glaube
auch nutzer finden
tja was soll ich sagen macht auf jeden
fall nichts zu sagen dass ich auf
irgendwelchen wolkenkratzer
herumklettern
aber es liegt mir schon ein bisschen
ähnlich muss schon sagen ich fand dass
vor allem immer krass weil ich hab echt
nicht so das gefühl dass ich selbst so
ein gesicht habe beziehungsweise
irgendwie so aussehen gibt auch noch
andere tun wird es gibt leute die sind
so typische gesichter ob denn jemand der
auch so aussieht steht zunächst das foto
ist auch in deinem klassiker deshalb
natürlich auch sehr oft höre ich auch
gerne weil die rede ist von grant gast
in dem schauspieler von flash und ihr
wisst ja vielleicht ich mag die serie
flash diskriminierendes ganz gerne rein
ganz auch ein bisschen frech ist
manchmal jetzt auf diesen fotos
vielleicht ein zu unbedingt vielleicht
hätte ich noch ein anderes was ein
bisschen ähnlicher auf sieht ja wie die
ähnlichkeit habe ich nicht also gut vor
allem die augen sind halt anders so
david hier richtig gerne eure meinung
hören ich weiß nicht genau wer das ist
auf dem foto vielleicht kann ich gleich
einen blenden ich habe dieses foto hier
von einer frau zugeschickt bekommen
würdet ihr sagen dass sie mir ähnlich
sieht also wirklich so zu sagen ich bin
weiblich weil ich finde so ein paar
gesichtszüge ähneln sich aber ich bin
mir nicht ganz sicher keine ahnung sagt
auf jeden fall noch ganz bis zum schluss
dran bleiben weil dann zeige ich euch
dieses eine foto oh jeder zu mir gesagt
hat das ist doch du und ich mich ähnlich
so nächstes bild habe ich hier auf
instrumentalwerke zugeschickt bekommen
dass wir jetzt nicht irgendwie ins
dauert also was glaube ich zumindest
wenn einfach ein kumpel von einer person
die meine videos schaut oder mainz
website so sieht er aus ich mache auch
ganz gern so diesen look dass ich meine
spüren so in falten legen sie ein
bisschen ähnlich aber auch nicht allzu
sehr
nicht dass fotos dieser typ hier das hin
zeit wieder die augen die komplett
anders aus denn als meine weil ich
einfach so dunkle bräunliche augen und
blaue augen
zu ihnen aber jetzt leute kommen wir zu
dem foto das genauso auf wie das ist der
typ ja also ich sinnvoll kann so weil
ich habe mir als erstes gesagt okay er
sieht schon ein bisschen aus wie ich
aber so sehr hat auch nicht da habe ich
irgendwelchen leuten die bilder gezeigt
opera ist denn dann haben wir echt
gedacht dass ich das bin auf diesem foto
bewährte tatsächlich so genau meine
augenfarbe und haben wir ähnliche nasen
wird schon sagen oder ähnliche werte
ein ohrring habe ich mich aber trotzdem
will ich auch schon öfters mal verlinkt
und sollte katie sieht aus wie du das
fand ich interessant gut ich denke mal
das video von heute noch einfach kurz
und belassen es dabei ich hoffe es hat
euch irgendwie gefallen oder euch
interessiert weil ich natürlich gucke
mir sowas ganz gerne an fällt mir noch
mal irgendwie ein video wo ich die
person von den leuten nach maß hin wo
ich einfach die fotos von meinen
doppelgänger nachmache schreibt mir auch
dass in die kommentare
da wünsche ich erst mal noch einen
schönen abend gehabt euch wohl vorher